what's good everyone michael here for
game tech and logitech sent us their
wireless charging ecosystem called power
play and i want to share with you my
thoughts and my experience with it and
whether or not it's actually worth your
time and money
[Music]
but before we get into it make sure
you're subscribed to our channel here at
gamespot
first off the key ingredient for power
play is actually the wireless charging
base so you'll get the
base right here which is actually made
out of rubber this is where the wireless
charging happens and you also get two
mouse surfaces a hard surface and a
cloth surface i actually prefer cloth
surface myself
but if you want a hard surface you'll
get one too along with the whole package
and it actually
sits on top of it very nicely almost
like it's magnetized so it's not gonna
slip or move around since the base is
rubber and the bottom is more adhesive
so it'll stick to the rubber base and
nothing's gonna be slipping around and
right here is where the charging comes
in you'll have to plug this in via usb
it's not exactly entirely wireless
because it will have to plug into a usb
port on your computer so when you plug
in the usb it sends the charging signal
down to the base the base then
communicates with the power cord that
you plugged into the bottom of your
mouse and that's what's gonna keep your
mouse charged if you're thinking to
yourself like oh well it's not wireless
it's wireless charging but you still
have to plug this part in so you'll have
these two things or three things if you
want to use the other mouse pad
and the final thing that it comes with
is
this thing right here which actually
picks up the wireless charging off of
the base
this is what you want to put into your
mouse but which mice can you actually
use with it well sold separately you can
get the g703
and this is the g903
it has the bottom part right here put
this into the bottom of the mouse
right here so you can get that pick up
that wireless charging signal now one of
the main concerns with using wireless
products and games is if you're going to
get any lag or latency i played
counter-strike global offensive all week
but i didn't have any issues with
sniping or making sure my aim was
precise or checking corners
now i think the whole power play system
is actually pretty sweet considering
that you can charge your mice and never
have to worry about plugging it in
because what's the point of having a
wireless mouse if you have to plug it in
in the middle of a gaming session but my
main concern is that it's going to cost
you
a lot
do you use wireless mice and games tell
us why or why not in the comments we
want to hear your thoughts and if you're
not subscribed to gamespot make sure
that you are and like this video if you
found it informative you thought it was
fun if you want to see more of this
stuff thanks for watching and i'll see
you next time